oh here here oh hey what's up Marty wait
I look like I left the left the seat
over here I saw it on the washer pick
that up and I will transport this in my
anus as is normal for the Rick and Morty
Joe that's how you get these oh and I
turn it on let me out
[Music]
that's a huge bottle wow those are giant
pills Oh God
what's inside that's not complicated
oh damn it what I do they throw it out
myself I like that they're small and
easy to lose one link cereal ending in a
number one in a letter no more than five
bands well alright
oh [ __ ] this is just like Jimmy and
Michaels PC building thing
two red bands no more than no more than
two blue bands
there you go carrot hammer now we're
talking there we go Wow
cool all right so you go one blue to red
five total oh [ __ ]
one blue no duplicates far total is it
broccoli plus cancel can will be metal
not dude get out of here
I don't need you you will be my intern
no don't close it [ __ ]
I want you to very carefully hold this
Wow okay
oh that was back here he saw a reality
[Music]
it's like well that's like a lawnmower
yep yep yep look okay ah no
[Music]
oops okay good good I think I charged it
whoa dang can I rip it off myself if the
toy doesn't flush stop crying
open the toilet tank make sure there's
liquid in the tank I think it's my right
I did trip but yeah that's a lot of wine
I don't think this is to scale wait for
it okay
okay I did it everyone let me leave this
oh yeah so I do
[Music]
[Music]